I didn't know these [ __ ] whales that
come from different part of the world
understand each other speak different
languages blew me away
dialects they have accents from
different parts same language different
dialects from different doors you know
what are they living together they were
attacking each other yeah I didn't
understand each other
SeaWorld yes yeah he's crazy
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot box and I'm have been Britton and
I'm Mike Tyson Mike we got a great guest
today man bring it in big-time foot we
can go back to the comedy we got our
brother Phil Dammers in the walrus
Whisperer Phil it's great to have you
man thanks for having me guys in this
company and fastly blessed so you tell
me that did war is is that their unique
as well yeah I mean the orcas as you
were just saying like they have
different languages and in fact from
different regions of the world they have
the similar language but different
accents I mean it gets when you start to
to really delve into the mind and the
heart and soul of these animals out
there they are people they are people
they have conflict with different with
different people of different places and
much like like we do and they interact
they have these different large crazy
meetings called where after I watch that
documentary blackfish I have I feel a
certain way about these I feel these
people and I human beings anything in
the hands and they don't understand and
they're trying to tell them something
they're not [ __ ] listening they're
frustrated and that's where that's where
the [ __ ] they trying to tell you at it
talking to people don't know the fun
play with this toy yeah Phil why don't
you bring us in for our for our audience
who don't know your story exactly what's
gone down you've been in a lawsuit with
Marineland the Canadian SeaWorld for six
years now
yeah we're pushing on seven years come
Feb you I and tell us tell everybody
just how this whole thing began like
where it started for you so I was an
employee of marine lens from 2000 to
2012 and during this time obviously I
established relationship to the animals
and whatnot in the amount I worked with
various species of animals
whales dolphins beluga whales seals sea
lions and of course walruses halfway
through my tenure this very strange
situation happened where we received a
baby wild-caught walrus and through this
traumatic sort of thing
incident we were you know we're trying
to get blood from her to assess their
their health well she got really freaked
out and at you know she was about 18
months of age I sort of tried to calm
and I put my hands in front of her face
and suddenly she took this deep breath
her nostrils went wide she looked up at
me and I couldn't tell you what happened
at the time but scientists today will
tell you that I imprinted on her in that
moment I became her mom she knows my
smell my she knows the sound of my voice
if I'm a hundred yards away and she
cares me whispering she starts freaking
out because she not wants to be directly
by my side so as you can imagine this
creates a conflict if down the road
suddenly that animal and the other
suddenly find themselves in a precarious
situation let's say their health starts
to decline and things start to get
really bad you know as was the situation
at Marineland so I really had to make a
choice am I gonna am I gonna sit by idly
why this is happening
am I gonna speak out about this so I
quit it was a difficult decision of
course cuz I'm having to separate myself
from an animal that needs me for her for
her own health and well-being but at the
time I'll admit that I I quit with the
understanding that I can still be
involved in her life that was the
understanding but we're at marine with
marine land but after a month of my
being away it was the longest that the
walrus smooshy and I had been away I
went to go visit her and they wouldn't
let me in the park they were doing
whatever they can to keep me away as
well what the [ __ ] going on here so I
get in and I run to where I know where
she is and you know she's away from the
public so you know she's hidden and when
I did see her she was you know she was
skinny she was lethargic she you know
she looked like a she didn't look like
she was gonna last very much longer
I knew that Marineland suddenly did not
we're not gonna keep their end of the
bargain so when the newspaper started to
call me like why did you quit why did
you quit I elected to speak very
publicly put my name and face to the
whole thing and they started printing
it became a big it became a big story of
course and this is in 2012 is actually
before the documentary blackfish so the
world was a different place and there's
just a little bit of backstory on that
the reason newspapers were interested in
why you left is because there had been a
lot of news flash but before black
please there's been a lot of attacks yes
you know there's been a lot of tack that
Willie Willie play so what happened was
essentially Marineland decided well
let's sue them because that's what
corporations do to regular citizens they
use the court system as a means to crush
them and imitate them well bankrupt
bankrupt them into silence and you know
often what happens in these cases is
you're forced to sign non-disparagement
agreements so you know I'm fighting
tooth and nail not to do that so
nonetheless they sue me but the mistake
they made is they decided in their
little fiction story of a lawsuit to
claim that I plotted to steal the walrus
and suddenly international press they
called me the kanye west of animal
training i don't know the [ __ ] that
means but suddenly there was headlines
around the world and you know and next
thing I know I'm on the Joe Rogan
podcast and next you know the profiles
going huge people are paying my legal
bills and no [ __ ] now Marineland goes
from this you know top of the chain
legacy burgeoning business to they are
now on their last leg just decimated
right but the lawsuit continues because
and just as well as I'm here now I'd
I've actually levied additional threats
on account of coming here don't you talk
about us you know well here I am talking
about you they're finished though now
they're pretty finished yeah it seems
like that it's been a long time coming
it's been a long six years I mean I have
to admit that as much as I'm sitting
here smiling and laughing and of course
I'm gonna I mean a wonderful supportive
place that's that's really important it
helps you but it's been a hell of a
[ __ ] ride like it so well they travel
from so far away to get their 100 years
hundreds of miles a hundred miles a day
let's say you imagine that in would out
of water the one the first movie I think
it came out just before blackfish the
Kove the Covell go dolphins and you see
that they heard these dolphins and it's
in Japan Taichi yeah trap oh they trap
them in this Cove they [ __ ] slaughter
a ton of them take babies and they
released the rest back in the ocean if
you can imagine so when they sit there
and they say hey we slaughtered 15 20 30
and they released another 50 of them
well you know half of those are gonna
die from trauma
so it's really an inaccurate figure when
they talk about the deaths it's a lot
it's girls those reverberations are
those types of of these animals
witnessing the stuff that just
reverberates through the oceans forever
how do you know to leave a cup Hina
don't have to kill them all if they're
not aesthetically pleasing and they're
too old mmm they're not good for meat so
they'll keep some for slaughter for me
they'll keep the young pretty ones for
captivity the rest of it just don't need
they get rid of them but a lot of them
of course they're those are their family
members that have just been sloppy
because the family members that the
babies have just been separated from I
mean this is really really traumatic
experiences and it changes their world I
mean oh so we don't even know the
psychological tendencies of these
dolphins the world because we find out
the elephants they thought they they
they they mourn like we do yeah yeah
they cry the same as dolphins will carry
their dead babies on their head in the
type of yeah yeah yeah for weeks on it
just last year in the Salish Sea there
was an orca who who held vigil for her
dead baby Orca calf literally was
mourning and kid and the family members
were supporting her and supporting that
the actual the the dead carcass for like
in excess of 40 days so I'm not mistaken
like an epic morning it it captured the
world it really captivated the world and
people are starting to recognize that
these these animals emotional
intelligence is Sophia so beyond
anything we can understand we at least
know now that putting them in tanks is
just absolutely outrageous yeah I mean
once you understand how intelligent
these animals are how emotionally
intelligent how much they feel and how
much they connect and how social they
are I can't go I can't take my daughter
to aquariums anymore
I always say as a clear conscience
friends don't let friends go to Sea
World
you know they just don't you can't do it
yeah Tigers like big Kathryn enough you
sleep in the bed with Judith and sleep
in the house of this [ __ ] then you can't
get them out
the impossible to get them out the house
with the big cats and possibly they
won't leave cuz they're just part of the
family well they're too big to get him
out what you gonna do if he sits down
that chariot slave that bone how much
you can't do nothing when I was in
Karakum when I was a kid I had this
dream like as a young child and it was
always to have a pet tiger it just it
was just seemed like the most outrageous
and crazy thing that could be conceived
and you had that man that's just
insanity the trip with them they're so
insecure that kill you if they think
you're leaving no wow
they think you're gonna leave them there
kill you I mean you can see the effects
of even cats and dogs when you leave the
against it's quite a traumatic thing I
look very often people would they leave
their houses and their dog to tear the
place like lying take their freak yeah
if they they see like him you see a male
tiger and a female tiger that's not
breathing feeling they're gonna kill
each other that happens very often in
zoos they try to they try to pair
animals from different facilities and
they they think they do the introduction
boom one of them dies they get killed we
think well that was a bust so obviously
walruses are on that same level of
emotional intelligence so when we as
trainers started to compare animals when
you deal with pinniped so that's like
your seal sea lions and walruses you
know seals and sea lions sort of stand
on their own they would I would compare
them more of these sort of puppy-dog you
know but walruses we always compare to
orcas we figured the only difference is
they don't move dogs yeah they really do
even in their demeanor in know them and
I've worked and interacted with them
became sort of friends with them they're
more interested in fish than anything
they're not very tactile they don't like
to be touched mean you could train them
and stuff but I did do some sort of
experimenting with them where I would
try to establish a legit friendship just
let me see let me sit beside you I'm not
giving you fish nothing let me see how
curious you are let me see if you allow
me to get close to you and you know I
did actually develop some pretty
interesting relationships that gave me
great perspective but you know they are
on a level that you know seals and sea
lions are just not walruses walrus is
emotional intelligence and just the
general intelligence is they're really
cunning animals are really smart
they're only I guess downfall is they
don't move very quick you know they got
pretty bad
eyesight and whatnot which doesn't serve
them well but they are really really
emotional I mean and my relationship my
anomalous relationship with the walruses
case in point of that and this is sort
of what I think is important for the
world to recognize when we consider
these animals we don't always consider
what their emotional capabilities are
well here I can demonstrate to you that
this animal loves me I mean now you now
if once you can once you can no longer
deny that animals love and that they
have these powerful bonds with their
family members and mothers especially
then you start to see just how brutal
some of the things we do to them are
mm-hmm yes Oh talk about the conditions
I mean obviously being isolated in a
tank or in a cage for most of your life
is already traumatic enough enough to
call cause psychosis but what are the
other conditions I mean is it just a
lack of understanding that this is
tolerated in these corporations I mean
is it it should be noted that these
facilities are not new you don't hear of
new pools and really I mean right the
last decade and there's our legacy
businesses from the 70s so the pools
themselves are just like absolutely
brutal these are acoustic animals in in
a in a concrete pool with filters and
and generators running at all times it's
blisteringly loud with the music going
and bunch of strange [ __ ]
looking at you all day and there's these
are these were really hyper chlorinated
pools if you want clean water with a
whale [ __ ] in it all day you're gonna
need a lot of chlorine you see the
glisten of the water when you show there
it's crystal clear that's because
they're getting pummeled with the with
the chlorine and that hyper chlorination
is pretty tough on them let's say really
tough long-term effects these animals go
blind I mean seals and sea lions yo you
rarely see you get animals what do you
fight proven you got those guys been
proven all day so you play with them for
an hour a day and so what's gonna happen
when you get in contact with them and
you turn your back on what they're gonna
do to you that's a good analogy really
they're in prisons they don't want to be
that they want out and the only thing
that helps them for the most part is
exercise but literally as if you spent
as much time as you could with them you
could never give them what they need I
mean you still these animals are in
cages 24 hours of the day they get
actual
attention if they're lucky eight eight
hours a day and the rest remain go
insane some of them may have to you have
to go insane well that's what happened
to tilikum he went nuts and he started
to kill all the start you went on the
killing spree with the train they had to
go insane yeah talking you were saying a
little bit about that earlier fill of
you know the orcas and it's so
interesting cuz you have to treat them
all like they're insane yeah you've got
to come from a place where you recognize
their trauma if you go in there
pretending like there isn't a problem
you're never going to understand them
yeah people are recognizing this now I
mean we are amidst what's called a
paradigm shift people now look at
animals in cages and and and
specifically are often whales and pools
because you know on account to the
documentary blackfish and they see now
that that's that's a mess whereas if you
know even as early as ten years ago you
could have had thousands of people
around a pool staring at what is
obviously a very depressed Orca and they
wouldn't know yeah now you look at you
can't you can't deny it
yeah the internet came and now you're
able to click a button and watch a live
feed of live migrating orcas and you see
the way they interact you see all
stealthy they are in their home in their
natural environment they've got that
large dorsal fin yeah so hi any wrecks
sailing through the like at insane
speeds and then you go to captivity and
they're literally just you know they're
just logging there and it's it's brutal
it there's something about it that they
if being in captivity breaks them you're
not looking at absolutely you're not
looking at a good movie i watch to
another movie i watch no else another
movie I watched it was about people arm
they were doing a documentary on orcas
and Dave and this particular guy was
doing research on great white sharks and
they put a remote thing on him and all
sudden her little arm and they followed
the thing like a couple weeks later it's
still fun and the thing that they had
the remote that they had the tracker
that they had in the white shark with in
the stomach of the ocher Walker he shot
yeah yeah
I've seen videos we watch
that's insane and I'm so fat the kilt
broke him in half
yeah and they hunt as armies imagine
like they're in large groups very often
so yeah great whites turn attack the
gray whales they bet they drown yeah
good they're too big for him they came
think Python I got a drown them crazy
man I find it remarkable at any time any
topic comes up on this show Mike you
seem to know so much about it it's
fascinating I feel like I'm I feel like
I'm speaking to a veteran about whales
it's insane
what I do Jags Mike you last weekend in
The Guardian bunny deuce that sounds
like your problem man I don't care go
rob a bank okay put some money down and
win like a man the matter with you this
is a [ __ ] going on right now
my bookie online [ __ ] it yeah Tim I'm
gonna use my bookie online and I think
that [ __ ] from them
hell no that's right my bookie online
you play you win they pay that's what
I'm talking about good all day every day
let's do it buh buh
[Music]
my bookie online has better bonuses and
more prop bets than any other sports
book period sign up for a chance to
receive $1,000 bonus at my bookie online
today
that's my bookie my B oh okay ie and
don't forget to use the promo code
hotboxing to activate the offer listen I
love knowing about life because we're
gonna die not knowing nothing about life
what we learned about life in our
lifetime it's so my Newt and we're gonna
almost die being idiots and we think we
know so much it's the very thing I don't
want that's why I'm a fan of the
medication of the plant genre I've taken
ayahuasca I I was intent on having some
DMT while I was here but it just didn't
quite work out but I haven't I haven't
smoked DMT I am keen on it I'd see the
come from whether that stuff come from
and how do you how does it know to
attack those parts of your brain that
make you respond the way that you
respond from it well the fact that it's
in our bodies and produced naturally
anyways it's a natural part of us it's
just a part of us that work why did the
total gain throughout more so than we do
yeah that is interesting what is it
about the five Meo that's different than
just the your traditional DMT that extra
methyl oxy group supercharges it through
the blood-brain barrier do you get that
at the front of the forehead the whole
blasting off no no I don't know what I
get I don't know maybe some but no one I
know um
I know um I go somewhere that you get
humble so fast you can't even fight it I
was saying to ebony earlier I think the
relevance and importance of this podcast
is that you're bringing together these
these groups of generally late alpha
males these successful people like we've
granted with the exception of me I'll
take that but no but you know you you
put these these these men amongst men in
circles here and what happens to
suddenly you find everyone speaking from
a place of vulnerability and of wisdom
and and of humility and I think it's
breaking down barriers whereas otherwise
you know people see just traditional men
and they just want to you know they have
a perspective of them and have an
expectation but here it's breaking all
of that it's it's really opening up
conversations and and really you're
demonstrating the sensibility of humans
here of men and I think that's really
important because I'm having
conversation with friends whereas I
wouldn't I mean a hockey dressing room
whereas normally were just chugging
beers and breaking bottles over I have
now instead we're talking about you know
I think I experienced some trauma back
then because yeah yeah it's crazy man I
have to extend some gratitude to you for
that because it's you changing the world
with this no one listen it comes down to
this we all struggle we all struggle
with this hypothesis of a god that we
know exists but we don't know him or her
or it we know it exists but we don't
have no relationship where we faith we
talk them but
you don't get the relationship that we
really know we want with it we don't
have understand why we here what is our
purpose who or who am i who are you
who's the first you lose the first mean
the first male blood line in my blood he
might he could have been a Chinese
European anything so many years we've
been here well knowing I mean I always
come back to this my belief that human
beings are the the epitome physical
manifestation of the universal mind of
the universal consciousness and we get
to have this individual experience of
this grand play like expressions
unfolding yes and we are wanting little
expression of that and this
consciousness that we have it's just we
get to have this experience because it
is built into the fabric of the universe
you know like our breath we breathe
because there is wind because there's
the air you know our bodies are made of
water an energy and star matter
[ __ ] that's blasted across the universe
and other galaxies where it's literally
the same components you know and for
whatever reason we're on this [ __ ]
rock careening through space having to
figure out what the [ __ ] we're doing
here but listen this is interesting
that's just I couldn't believe that too
but listen if any of if any of the
species beside the human being if it's
all in Aisle eight if it doesn't lift
this world is over the human species we
all die Discworld continues to flourish
yes yeah the [ __ ] yeah no it's bad as
world die here we're done all the trees
die we done have we done the world
flourish
what's the [ __ ] man I think that I don't
want to say no but that really fair girl
you know it were useless here what is
that purpose yes exactly I know my
experience with this hole people say to
me like you know what were you thinking
when you made this decision what were
you thinking when you how did you come
to make this decision and you know in
retrospect I say I haven't made a single
decision they've all been made for me
and what I'm blessed with is just being
a witness to it all I have a I have a
the best seat in the house
you're my experience but I haven't made
a decision it's all been made for me
it's well said no I totally agree
thousand yeah who are we who we think
we'd I were going to help everything
everything that we're experienced has
been made up time and space we imagine
going somewhere with no time to spare
I took the toy I wasn't wearing no time
and space and it was frightening there
not knowing anything my whole life
flashed in front of me from the
beginning of my life to the end of my
life and now I'm still here
now what everything's gone now what
what's the next level I'm still here
waiting I'm not dead yet my energy still
vibrating I don't have nobody I don't
see my body but I'm still here my
feelings fear and all I should still
going on I mean Mike that's why you
carry on them
that's why phil is you know being a
voice for the voiceless that's why I'm
doing what we do and these people well
so the villain of the story is dead the
owner of the park he was very old man he
obviously did not win he and I didn't
see eye to eye
he was the sole controlling mind of the
entire company he's the one that wanted
essentially what I'll call here revenge
but he's passed away so I don't see why
it makes any sense for this to continue
however it is said that there is a death
wish of sorts for this lawsuit to
continue and it's evident in how marine
lands lawyers operating because it's
just they only exclusively operate with
hostilities and you know I'm trying to
bring a little bit of humility to this
story and trying to offer for them like
some type of peace but they're just not
you know in Los lawsuits aren't rational
so we're in what I would call hard
negotiations and I'm willing to
negotiate with hostilities as long as I
have to I mean I've got a hell of a
large voice now on account of the fact
that I've been responding to Marineland
in kind and I've been blessed with the
tools to do so on account of broadcasts
of the source I know what's going I know
how these people think you know being a
Blackman these animals don't got no
[ __ ] rights our only the animals with
whatever they deserve is what I think
they deserve they don't know [ __ ] about
the damn [ __ ] they don't know anything
about the [ __ ] animals the inner
animal drew attention they make money
there's nothing about an animal
temperature and nothing
Marineland knows the writing's on the
wall finally they they're still trying
to silence me and in the strangest way I
have to thank them for this fight
because they they've brought this to me
and and you know they made me they made
me stronger they brought me here you
know they took me to a place where I
have to exercise a lot of introspection
to be able to sustain this fight you
know I've had I've been tested and you
know the greatest test is yourself
that's for sure and in my ayahuasca
experience you know I witnessed my death
but more so I witnessed the death of
what I would call my caricature the
thing that I thought I was the thing
that I sort of brand you know the hat
with my shirt and I saw this sort of
cartoon version of me to die and the
reemergence of a more raw real me just
like a more you know I got a hell of a
better perspective now I now feel like
this is an absolute blessing like
whereas other people would call this a
nightmare it's been a blessing I think
the thing when I took the toad man died
right away quit whoa whoa hey whoa I'm
dead [ __ ] like your consciousness would
totally you felt that you're like I just
died yeah [ __ ] just took this hit and
I'm dead [ __ ] yeah I'm a dumb
[ __ ] why did I do that
oh [ __ ] it's over now oh that would be a
depth of fear that's the ultimate depth
of fear and discomfort I just I imagine
to come with discomfort or was it
something you're at peace with the new
in the immediate moment would it right
away
right
take me you know that's what a lot of
people need is that to experience that
fear to come down from a place of that's
so ego driven and that's the thing that
I've had to sort of try to don't you
take the total you're not afraid to die
anymore yeah that would be that's the
thing I still want to shed a little bit
more I want it's a fear of death that I
think is the root of all fear and mine
was very intent and and really inspired
my my speaking out in many ways
obviously with the prospect of the
walrus dying but also in that you know
you just become scared that way this is
very simple do you think our God our
universe you know who made us the way we
are and the way we can really want to
hurt us after we die and send it to some
bad place really do you think so I think
like when I go under the told there's no
right or wrong there's no Lord there's
no police it's just reality you know I
mean that's what most of us are afraid
of our own conscience what we know that
we never forget something we believed we
did wrong and no one knows anymore we're
so afraid to be transparent in the world
we live in now the afraid of judgment
and stuff that's why I think this
podcast serves just you know a lot of
people well where do you think that
comes from dead myth is fear it is a
primal instinct it's one of the things
that keeps us alive we are meant to be
afraid because that helps us survive is
there a [ __ ] saber-toothed tiger
around the corner is somebody gonna kill
me am I the thinnest make sure you wear
clean underwear just in case that
happened you have to take you off your
pants and make sure you have clean
underwear and the word clean or
something seeing black features say that
right and I'm saying I'm saying if I'm
dead why are you gonna keep my underwear
clean and I rarely who I'm gonna
accident into something and I'm it's all
about somebody mother in the old black
world
somebody must have got in trouble a to
think they pants listen to me had
shitstain defending their drawers and
that's been legendary through all the
history of the black world always have
clean underwear on just in case you get
in trouble you have to take your pants
off so I wonder who would the guy with
the shitty under words
well in 1980 1805 or something something
in the way a black kid who's the guy
with the city underwear got to go back
in the history books and just find the
guy with the nickname shady somewhere
but that fear of judgment like we're the
[ __ ] man I guess it's just we don't want
to be because in the tribal setting that
means being exiled yeah that means being
isolated that means being killed even
right it's funny I'll post something
that in fact it was a very there was a
very controversial photo which is not
controversial in the least but Joe Rogan
and I he was in Toronto so we went for
dinner
and he took we did a selfie outside of
this restaurant and the restaurant is
known for serving meat and you know the
post goes up and you get a thousand
double thumbs up comments but then you
get the one in a thousand that's don't
you know where this meat comes from and
they start hammering you and it's then
seems the thousand of praise and all
these different nice comments are gone
out the window because now you're just
like oh [ __ ] they just are feeling bad
for that judgement and you know you seem
to focus more often on the judgment and
the negativity when you when you you
know when you're I guess when people are
essentially judging you and that's the
thing that I'm learning to just not
focus on you know can you imagine this
man to being stage everyone to pull any
but one person's not applauding you know
you're nothing and putting your focus is
true that's true it's true even a wise
man I mean I have handy mother you might
be high so I might be wrong you may be
on the phone side but he's not
applauding that [ __ ] your head up
everybody's not alone one person under
9,000 and you're [ __ ]
you know it's really interesting because
that really resonates with me looking
back at my football career again all
these people man you're awesome you're
the best I have your [ __ ] you're the
man you're tough is [ __ ] you're awesome
and like the few individuals who I don't
know some insane [ __ ] on I said yeah
you can't you're [ __ ]
good can't please everybody right okay
now and I would focus on that one
[ __ ] who said something you know
critical about my game or whatever it
was but now I don't know what it is I
don't know how I've got here but it's
everything I've done every step I've
taken every breath every [ __ ] 30
minutes added on top of each other of
meditation day after day I don't know
this connection with spirit but I could
see a thousand [ __ ] yous and get one guy
who says dude you're awesome I love you
and I will focus all of my attention on
that one that's the conscious shift that
needs to happen people need to just
respect the good much well my friend
here my friend spandy has a great saying
further to what you were saying with the
you know you got a thousand people
applauding and one person not is every
time I talked I'm just like oh [ __ ] dude
this is the co system eeeh dude your
mind creates everytime 99 problems and
none of them happen if none of them
happen but it eats you up and none of it
happens when I brought him in here today
and introduced you to his name's Andy
Andy by the way he's a street performer
and we're gonna be in yeah we meet each
other all over the world pindy because
he's always traveling and I call him my
emotional support it's great but he's
always you know he's real humble dude
he's traveled the earth he's he's been
he's been homeless he sees you know he's
had money here and then did that his
perspective is amazing in life he
actually had a grandmother who survived
the Holocaust lost all of her her
husband included family and everything
came back came to Canada and she had
always instilled in him this level of
happiness and perspective and he is just
he's just a wealth of wisdom because
that's passed on you know and he just he
just knows to live it up he dances
around the world in spandex man like you
know he's there's nothing you can do but
smile because he's got its got the gift
it's contagious it's laughter everything
but he's got that wisdom your mind
creates 99 problems that never happened
never has so true so true he's saying in
my whole life I just got by that one
never existed hey you haven't faith in
the league this yeah okay if I could
divest myself of all the
different things I thought was gonna
happen at the beginning of this journey
I would have I would have I wouldn't
have had an iota of anxiety it was all
anxiety over things that never happened
so how do you feel about zoos
I don't like zoos that much I've when
I've sorted and jaded right
what is ooh zoos where they have animals
like not not marine animals some
enlightening no no I'm not I'm not a big
fan on marine animals you know the in in
some cases they're doing some good work
but normally when you get into sort of
their finances you see how little money
actually gets allocated to this type of
work but okay that's that's my criticism
of that but there's certain animals that
just really not shouldn't be in
captivity I think that there are some
that it's fine there some just should
not look at this this is another
catch-22 so a tiger if something if um
it's nice man in the Ziller 13 maybe 15
years it might be three years in the
wild what do you say about that I say it
lives 10 really shitty years I think he
would rather live it's three in the wild
I think it wasn't serve its purpose if
you take away killing from a tiger what
the hell is it anymore right if they're
feeding a meat and that's it what is it
anymore
yeah Mike you know about King Leopold oh
yeah from Belgium yeah and he went to
anyone to umm to Africa will play Congo
with the Congo yeah and so he made these
guys suck the rub out the tree get the
rub out the tree get the oil get the
gold and they chopped their hands off
and all that shady delicious he did a
number on those guys
brutal and well the reason I bring him
up is because they brought pygmies over
and put them in cages in the u.s. really
yeah yeah us with cage anything at the
Bronx Zoo they had it's the story of
this guy over dengue he was a pygmy from
the Congo
and there was some I don't know Explorer
hunter of the time at the time an
American guy he was basically hired to
go get one of these people and two of
the two in there but yeah - white people
- yeah you know they they put him in the
zoo and they had people watching them
seeing how they interact I don't know if
they were homeless they they were two
white people and they put him in it and
they lived it all anybody was just
looking at them it's crazy
what they were [ __ ] from everybody's
lived in life or infant anybody actually
they weren't even there it's crazy man
it's time has changed our perspective I
mean there was a time and that was fine
it's just like there's there was a time
when whale captivity is fine just like
there will be a time when zoos do not
exist yeah other than for the purpose of
reintroduce reintroduction of you know
at-risk species one I mean I can see the
validity of validity in that but if
they're not being reintroduced in a
while then those animals have no purpose
anyways like it's just you if you look
at from the animals perspective are you
doing any animal a favor keeping it
alive but not allowing it to actually
live like its purpose I don't know I
just some species of animals they seem
to do fine elephants big cats whales
apes monkeys they just did there I don't
think they should ever be confined and
and taken away from their natural
environment I mean that's they they just
need to remain there do we should do our
best to protect and and and support that
to give them their world let them live
their world right and I think then once
we get that once we really understand
that we're gonna have a lot more harmony
I think we think we as humans carry a
lot of guilt maybe even unconsciously if
some of the destruction we're doing
because like you say which you know
we're so connected to the world we're
made of water and everything else -
can't help but not feel it's [ __ ]
plight you know its perils absolutely I
mean Joe on the podcast yesterday with
Joe he made a good point you know how
would you feel if somebody kicked your
door down killed you and your spouse
kidnapped your kids and put them in a
cage for the rest of their life I mean
that's what's happened
right you guys been done yeah you know
it's a strange fun like what is the
function of evil because it seems like
it's it's is that the path of least
resistance is you just be evil
no no evil is um evil is put in on in
our life but we can overcome it mmm and
grow stronger and as long as the evil
laugh ever belongs it laughs were able
to fend it off it won't destroy someone
overwhelm us you know so evils meant to
be fought only the under good leave is
meant to have its encounters that's how
we separate who we are we find that who
we truly are from that encounter I mean
that's been my experience in this
journey I wouldn't be Who I am now but I
always was I just didn't know it you
know yeah and I believe some evil
happens with people out and being
unconscious that this is really evil you
know somebody they just think they're
doing it somebody's right son since the
beginning of his existence is his
grandfather the great-grandfather that
has been passed down that way and it's
been okay ever since how can it be wrong
yeah if my whole adjustment told me that
you're bad you're bad for your life
don't matter if feelings don't matter
why am I gonna say they're wrong or be
convinced yeah like you John Lilly is
know tell me about him
Phil probably can give you a good John
Lilly was like this I don't know I'll
give you what I can what I can offer is
kind of this you know I had a unique
mind that's for sure but he was a
scientist he was performing a bunch of
different experiments with dolphins and
stuff and he did acid and started
communicating telepathically total a
dolphin he's trying to bridge the gap of
your education so he actually flooded a
house and had dolphins and so he and his
assistant would live with them and it's
worth googling to get the depth of it
all but you know it includes some like
strange sexual encounters and lots of
use of drugs and whatnot but he would
eventually go on to invent the float
tanks you're familiar with float tanks
where you go into these chambers yeah
that's
John Lillian can't exactly yes he's
doing great books and crazy stuff and
yeah I show Joey yesterday that he's a
Joe unbeknownst to him and definitely
unbeknownst to John Lily or whoever
probably put the picture on is actually
his photo it's dead set photos on the
big gun on one of the books is freaking
hilarious uncanny but it's totally
fitting isn't it yeah it's interesting
how he went from that interspecies
communication who studies that who
thinks I'm gonna take a bunch of LSD
well probably taking the LSD is what led
him to want to do that really because
whereas before there would be that there
wouldn't be that bridge gap sudden he's
just like oh wait [ __ ] that's a belief
in ancient times we had a different
relationship some animals did we have
now yeah and I wonder people had trained
tigers and lions and I said listen man
you're stumped for war yeah listen
forget this all right I see people in
Africa now they got trained hyenas wild
hyenas trained like dogs hanging out
with them playing with the net monsters
too how do you do that yeah it's an
interesting idea about why we haven't at
least in the West domesticated any more
animals it's been like and so that's a
process that takes maybe hundreds of
thousands of years writings of thousands
I don't know like happen overnight
in ancient time they had everything
domesticated they had the elephant
domesticate they had the dog the Romans
had the dogs um [ __ ] them
domesticated during war the dogs were in
war with the wrong you you have to
wonder if then maybe they were using
instead of dominance because it's
training now is an animal captivity is
based on dominance you dominate the
animals but it seems like as we become
more humble and we try to bridge the gap
of communication maybe back then they
were so freaking genius and conscious
that they were able to communicate with
the animals after more trusting
relationship without having to starve
them and beat up listen no I'm gonna
tell you son another crazy story about
animals like the Christians used to
always have pigeon make them
communications across like a thousand
messages like a thousand miles during
the crusade so the Muslims started
thinking eras are okay they trained
Falcons yeah some cats
that's how that started that's so crazy
it got so crazy encounter there [ __ ]
attack they read the method okay so they
counted him
that's how Falcon ings started that's so
fascinating dude no it started with the
poor the peasant started the first and
some royal sword and said I want then
just stole the guys thing and they had
they thought those guys had never heard
of the intelligence of crows I mean
we're finding out that these are like
really into animals capable of like
pretty complex mathematical equations
that they're solving puzzles yeah that I
mean even in there's something mystical
about those animals right when you see a
freaking crow over your shoulder it
seems he knows something you normally
see those little crows dodging yeah yeah
yeah they use tools in the wild even I
mean the crows we're finding out are mad
geniuses and that's gonna scare the [ __ ]
out of you once you start to delve into
the intelligence of animals that you
thought were outright stupid it's so
dumb it's I think it's ignorant for us
to not understand that animals have
consciousness and thoughts and emotions
no Evan listen they were here before us
we learned from them you never heard
somebody say man you punch like [ __ ]
tight no you punch like a [ __ ] bull
yeah that's good though the animals were
here before us I mean we imitated them
yeah you imagine people were so magnin
when they probably had babies they
probably killed him right away ate them
right away when we first started having
babies didn't know what it was you know
it wasn't a cost so much [ __ ] pain I
made you miserable you hated it it's so
interesting because I've thought about
that they killed the Memphis like if you
were a cave person way back in the day
one of the first early humans and you
got pregnant and you gave birth what the
[ __ ] are you thinking well some people
come and you've never seen someone
commit suicide and killed the baby took
the baby with the demon probably and
killed the baby do it over cliff it
makes you appreciate living today
we talk about the father baby was
probably a father you know somebody
complicated your tribes and killed
everybody in the neighborhood something
yeah and it's a common practice in
captivity to breed family members and
and didn't just do it the annals are
worth so much the orc is in the case of
workers they're worth so much go ahead
do it right Tilikum was the father of
life well I can't hundreds right I don't
know if it's hundreds I'd say not
hundreds but none he did father a lot of
concurrent collection one of which i ikk
actually became in possession of a
marine land canada and we worked with
Ike and as I mentioned before Ike was
starting to show some some violent
traits and some mental health issues
Telekom's sons who look him soon and he
was at Marineland i worked with him and
you know things started to get a little
scary with him and we would tell
SeaWorld we were in constant
communication with him of course and
SeaWorld insisted that
Marineland put up barriers to keep
people away from you starting to lunge
at us lunch at the trainers lunch at the
general population and marina I would do
nothing of it because no one tells
Marineland what to do so SeaWorld sued
Marineland and successfully got that
Orca removed from real and now I will
tell you here that I think that if they
didn't he was gonna kill someone he was
gonna kill someone yeah and it might
have been my girlfriend who was what it
was one of his head trainers really
knows you know sometimes we had pinion
days know the [ __ ] I'm gonna piñas no
they fly hide and all the pinion to fly
longer these know that [ __ ] we're on the
ground always cocking the girls are
coming closer they're beautiful
yeah I've worked with some really really
really amazing animals I am look back to
war but that the worth have the offer
the wars the walrus so here's what's
happening now there's you know three
walruses died in the last 18 months
[ __ ] marine land very quietly no one
you know they don't announce it I find
out I announce it they make a statement
it's ugly PR aim of hate you last
amen you know they're coming after me
with everything they've sent like goons
to my house man hired tough guys like
wow yeah yeah I got a little documentary
if you go to the website save smooshy
calm so that's sa ve s mo shi calm
there's a short documentary but that
includes video like sort of the tough
guys coming around and the owner himself
stalking my house and you know they've
resorted to just absolutely everything
so basically now there's only two
walruses left that I know of
at Marineland you know they're otherwise
they're not even on public display
Marineland keeps them hidden from the
from the public but they come out at the
end of the show for the sake of a simple
wave the problem is smooshy comes out
and all she wants to do is look for me
it's all she's ever done in the last
seven years so Tommy um these places
with me please Marineland me world Suzy
were places that's like that's almost
like would you let those them the pin
out the top HAP show with those daily
and like the carnival that's like a
carnival more huh
it's exactly what it is that Marineland
these animals serve only two for
entertainment purposes they're still
trainers imagine even in this day
despite all the criticism and the the
the the essential downfall of marine
land and sea worlds you know sea was
getting decimated as well you know we're
part of a global conscious shift marine
land is still jumping off of dolphins
faces to loud music and they're still
standing on beluga whales and everything
it's as if they're one of the women cut
down what do they do the animals so and
this is where this project that I'm
proud to be sort of involved with is
called the whale sanctuary project we're
looking to erect a site where it'll be
sort of a transition we can take these
animals from captivity put them in a in
a cove like area like a big bay fenced
off and under human care there's going
to be efforts to very responsibly
reintroduce those that can to the wild
otherwise they can live their lives in
this place with a sense of dignity and
they're gonna feel the rhythms of the of
the ocean there'll be live fish
available for them you know the water
will be just perfect and yeah they'll
still be under human care but that that
is the future so that's coming so my
hope is some of marine lends animals go
there otherwise what happens to them
right now is there's a big sell-off
learning that is essentially dissolving
I mean this is what I
think okay I don't to be sued for lying
but I think that they're done they've
sold off some property theirs we know
they're selling off animals that we know
they've already committed to making it
known that they're gonna be getting rid
of other ones they say it's under the
guise of responsible not having enough
space for them but who's related to
dolphin yeah they're actually dolphins
yeah yeah third largest dolphin another
amazing animal dolphins you see them in
the wild which I'm blessed and you
probably can any day you want I mean
just drive down the Pacific Coast
Highway and you're gonna see them out
there yeah I know I did that's awesome
some of my friends boat and we saw some
feels and we they were on the deck and
we walk them and they were big a little
feel shock the chafing they're big yeah
yeah I've worked with like seven hundred
pound male see a big piece yeah and
their bites are nasty actually a little
bit of scars not too bad there but I got
bit by a grey seal and but their mouths
are so poisonous that you know as soon
as you go to hospital if for a it's
funny when you say I got bit by a seal
they're like like I live in Niagara
Falls Ontario there's no seals for
hundreds and hundreds and maybe
thousands of miles so but what they do
is they draw that line with the pen and
they say listen if that thing if that if
this inflammation goes beyond this line
you better get in here because you know
you're at risk of having your blood
poison it's it's it's it's in captivity
and animals and zoos and whatnot they've
got the nastiest bite the most dangerous
Wow yeah big 750 pound males who've yeah
yeah but they're nice they're nice I
mean you just got to be you know make
sure they're well fed you do your best
Ethan Lee they must have good lover
because everything worth to eat them to
show this orcas when I was in the Salish
Sea watching the wild orcas they were
there that some transients were killing
a seal and the person on the book could
smell it she was like oh there's a seal
being slaughtered and she was she could
smell she could smell she could smell it
boom in the distance you could see some
activity some dorsal fins like sort of
coming over the perimeter of the water
or the ridge and then we got there and
yeah sure [ __ ] they're feasting on the
seal is crazy yeah it's crazy
smell it yeah twerkus transient orcas
smell the blood in the air taste it
almost
sweet I'm like I got a memo right but no
startled oh man choose is negative I
think if I'm not mistaken it was it was
the boat was called Maya's legacy so you
know if you're ever in Washington State
or not yet definitely go check out some
orcas there's nothing more humbling and
and awe-inspiring than seeing animals in
their natural environment and especially
orcas because they are special okay
I thought I thinkwe with the American
named Matthew the agretti BC polar bear
would sit around 2,000 pound he jumped
in a war with he looks like an ant he
was so small he was too thick for the
world though walking just full of it
yeah it couldn't be a skin I saw an
episode of our I believe it's called our
planet on BBC and what happens what's
happening now is on account of the fact
that there's less ice floes for the
walruses to stay on while they're on
Hunt's they now are congregating in in
thousands on these beaches and some of
these beaches have like these large
cliffs and whatnot in the walruses are
finding themselves at these Heights not
account to that fact that they're a herd
animals would be that bad vision and
what not is during sort of times of
panic or you know any something you know
whatever triggers this response these
walruses are suddenly finding themselves
jumping over these cliffs and falling
down these these huge distances Heights
and on account to the fact that they're
they're so big and blubber either
they're bouncing away they die they die
but it's like brutally slow and so that
matters powerful image to watch what's
happening to these animals are just
they're literally plunging off the cliff
side it's so now you know the Internet's
talking about it so yeah it's
heartbreaking but we need to see this we
have to see this right now yeah you can
know it's the BBC footage so I imagine
it's out there our planet I think it's
episode 2 who's in charge of this like
if I didn't say hi on behalf of my dad
who's a big fan he would be disappointed
so I gotta tell you Burma and and in
fact dancing Roger hey thank you I do
like you got a shout out to my mom Danny
in the house yes that's his son here one
of my first memories in fact of my
seeing my mom quite
was the day custom auto died and really
yeah and she's I remember she was
leaning over the tables and I said
what's wrong she said you know a good
man died today and she was just to
distract I didn't understand just you
know a little bit young but and that was
that day yeah so I've now to find myself
here is it's a poignant experience and
I'd really really God is doing he did
things so shout out much love to my mom
Diane much love to Diana she's in
Welland
it's a small place but please say
shuttle to Welland and the well endures
Mike fleet alright shout out the Welling
and the well endures oh yeah legendary
oh yeah oh yeah there we go
what was the video just look up walrus
cliff Navy walrus is falling off cliff
no there it comes up will you that it's
listening to us [ __ ]
you know I didn't go and throw high
there's a look there's no space for them
they're limited they're climbing on top
of each other literally there's
thousands of them see there's no space
for man they don't go down things well
they're not built in but they're real
top-heavy you know yeah I mean they
probably can't move that well on where
it's it's a tragedy that they climbed it
shouldn't do it the first place they're
really good climbers but they can't get
down from things and I saw this
personally in captivity I couldn't
believe that though to climb anything
but [ __ ] I can't watch this [ __ ] dude is
so bad his eyes oh my god
[Music]
they already broken I already watched
this so I don't have teeth we've been
partly coming out in that oh he fell
right through the bottom of the admin
tool another one all up dead if not
they're dying you know we got to watch
these things we got to know what's
happening this is it this is a direct
this is climate change in the you know
this is what's happening the ice floes
are gone they have nowhere to stay when
they're hunting in this case he's
jumping he's just have enough once the
momentum takes you and you know you're
going your tendency is to try to you
know mitigate that [ __ ] they're flying
off cliffside that's brutal man how can
people support you man save smooshy calm
I got a GoFundMe please help me out my
lawyers are always very busy but you
know we're keeping my voice in the game
and that's what's keeping this paradigm
shift alive and flowing and man I see a
day where I'm being able to raise my
hand and victory and I can't believe it
it's gonna be soon you know seven years
ago if you told me that you know if I if
you told me that seven years ago maybe I
wouldn't have had the energy to get
through to through it all maybe it's the
fear that kept me going yeah but by
virtue of I can only call it a miracle
I'm still in this thing so so yeah you
can help me up there and otherwise you
know friends don't let friends go to
Marineland and be world [ __ ] Marineland
yeah well [ __ ] oh I love you Mike man I
love you Evan go into the wild mouths
hey brother
well thank you so much - it's been a
it's nothing but a blessing for me and
it's a truly humbling thing to be here
III believed and trusted the universe
the day the decision was made for me and
and being a witness there's no better
seat in the house so thank you for
having me and thank you just generally
for this because this is change in the
world that's great thank you dude thank
you thank you great at Mike and good
staff Mancini's Warwick's going yeah
that was not I'm thinking only photos I
break it [ __ ] yeah
tusks watch my documentary though might
give me the 14 minutes of it okay we'll
watch it
hey brother we've got your back man
thank you again you're the man Phil the
walrus whisperer check him out
all right everybody that was another
episode of hot box and check us out be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
hot boxing with Mike Tyson head to our
website hot box and podcast.com for all
the latest we've got our merch up there
check it out great stuff Mike another
awesome episode brother give [ __ ] I'm
out of here
[Music]